My friends, if you know me, you know, it
brings me no pleasure whatsoever to tell
you that we unfortunately are seeing exactly
what I've been expecting, which is that the case
spikes in Corona virus in what I guess we're
calling wave three, even though I know we never
really got past the first wave, but at least we
can call it spike number three. The case spike
was inevitably going to lead to a spike in deaths.
And it's happening. I would love to have believed
it wasn't going to happen, but there was no reason
to believe it wasn't going to happen. And it's
happening yesterday. One thousand two hundred and
twenty five more people died in the United States
of Corona virus. And we now are seeing the
leaders in terms of deaths. California, Texas,
Florida, no surprise that some of the largest
population states, also Illinois, Ohio and Kansas.
This is the highest number of
reported American deaths in one day,
dating all the way back to August 26. And now,
even when we look at a seven day rolling average,
which shows us the sort of general direction of
the numbers, a very clear uptick in the number of
deaths. The total number of deaths now through
the pandemic in the United States, 227 nearing
228 thousand. Now, remember, this matters because
we saw the Trumpy in. Right, saying through Spike
number two. And as we have entered Spike number
three, that cases may be up, but cases are up
only because of testing. Now, when we looked at
the number, we saw that that wasn't the case.
But they would also insist we're not going to see
deaths go up because it's younger people getting
sick who are less likely to die were better at
treating it. It's a less serious strain and or
various combinations of these and other ideas
as well. Some of it is plausible. I mean, it's
plausible that the deaths won't go up as much as
they might have with this number of cases if they
were in April or July, because we do have some
treatments that have been shown to be effective in
helping prevent death and some of the most serious
cases. It's true that at least over the summer, we
were seeing sort of a push towards younger people
being the ones getting infected because I guess
older folks were taking it more seriously. But
clearly, when you have this number of new cases,
you are going to see a spike in deaths. And we are
now heading. I mean, we we can't ignore it. We can
ignore it. Trump has been trying to ignore it. But
it would be it would not be prudent to ignore that
we may be heading towards the most difficult phase
of American life from a public health standpoint,
maybe in 100 years in the United States this
fall. And when we talk about wave three,
it is true that we've not really
had a break since wave one,
but maybe spikes are the right terms recalled
that we had spike number one in mid-April
to about 35000 cases a day. And then we got down
to 20000 cases a day and things started to reopen.
And that caused a second spike in late mid
to late July of about 75000 cases per day.
And then presumably thanks to some social
distancing guidelines being observed and then
also the fact that because it was summer and
warm in just about every part of the country,
people were spending more times outdoors. We
saw cases start to decline again. But this time,
instead of dropping to 20000 a day, the bottom was
only about 30000 cases a day. And then once again,
now we are on the upswing regularly, seeing 60,
70000 cases per day. They told Foushee he was
crazy when he said we could see 100000 cases
a day in the fall into winter. And indeed,
if you look at the trajectory, we may well be
heading to 100000 coronavirus cases per day.
And the reality is that even Will, with a lower
death rate, which hopefully we would have compared
to the spring and summer because of better knowing
how to manage cases, we could easily end up with
15 hundred two thousand cases a day. And this
is very quickly getting very, very ugly. Now,
Donald Trump will tell you, given the opportunity
to go back to February, January, February, March,
he would not do anything differently when it
comes to dealing with the virus. And in fact,
he said it directly on a town hall with
Eric Bolling just about 48 hours ago.
Take a look with Koven. Is there anything that you
think you could have done differently if you had
a mulligan or a do over on one aspect of the way
you handled it? What would it be? Not much. Look,
it's all over the world. You have a lot
of great leaders and a lot of smart people
all over the world who came out of
China. China should have stopped it.
Donald Trump would not have done
anything differently. Now, it is true
that Europe. In countries and
countries, in other parts of the world,
Argentina, for example, are seeing huge spikes as
well. But we're looking at our country and we're
looking at whether Donald Trump's handling
has earned himself a second term. And the
answer is obviously no. Now, one other difference
between the United States and other countries is
I know we never really got past wave
one, but if we use the terms spikes,
we are heading into spike number three, the spikes
we are seeing in places like France and Italy as
examples. These are their second spike. So while
their second spike, much like our second spike,
is worse than their first spike, we are already
on Spike number three. And therefore we're not
even comparing apples to oranges anymore when
we compare what's going on. Another country.
Sorry. We are now comparing apples to oranges.
We're really comparing apples to yak meat.
To be perfectly frank, because the situations
are so different and the handling has been so
different. Different. And when you look at
what's happened here, when you've seen Trump
and Republicans ridicule those who wear masks,
Trump even ridiculing Joe Biden onstage in the
first debate when Trump in all likelihood had
Corona virus already. We we need a change. And
what is Thanksgiving going to look like in four
weeks if this spike continues to grow? It's
horrifying to think about. And we have some really
we're waiting for a vaccine, among other things.
And we have some really important vaccine
news, which I want to talk about next.